[Music]
let's see here let's uh let's do let's
do this this is good i just want to
point out people think we're mean frozen
sent me this in chicago there is a
growing group of young black athletes
and they're learning how to play a new
sport while gaining
i don't think i should
but okay
in chicago there is a growing group of
young black athletes and they're
learning how to play a new sport while
gaining a life-saving skill in the water
this is racist right i feel like it's
racist it feels wet
like black black kids are getting in the
pool
being an item on the news
in itself feels right it feels racist
right like wow those black people are
learning how to swim
with the details
right that just feels weird
they go to julian high school and that's
a high school that is known for
basketball baseball and football
no [ __ ]
i mean do they have a lot of top you
know recruits out of there too i'm gonna
guess this feels like when you're not
trying to be racist and you're being
extra right you're being more racist
than we've ever been but not water polo
until now
[Applause]
[Music]
it's not the kind of sport the julian
jaguars are known for but okay stop i
can't make those jokes you're doing this
the news is saying this i'm not saying
it
but these days water polo is appealing
to more and more black athletes coach
marshall yeah it just makes it harder
for them to steal the ball because
they're in water
people tell students if you know how to
play soccer you can learn this sport in
soccer you have to use your you know you
kick them with your foot in this
particular case i didn't know that
in water polo you only catch the ball
with one hand so how is it like on the
ground with one hand it sounds like oh
it's like soccer because black people
also don't do it
it's like it's just like soccer like you
know soccer you got to do everything
with your feet right yeah well in this
game it's just like soccer you do
everything with your hands he's like
wait what
that sounds nothing like soccer it
sounds more like football
well they that's how soccer's played in
rand mcnally
it sounds more like basketball to an
extent right okay i didn't i didn't hear
that wrong she said water polio yeah did
she really yeah okay i got it back up
but she's on the water polo coach polio
but she's the one it's in charge of it
she's saying it wrong
hold on let's see we'll see
is it further back or right around here
right around there all right here we go
foot in this particular case in water
polo you only catch
it sounds like she said
a word yeah
yeah i want to
i want to give people [ __ ] at all times
but it sounds like she said in water
polo you but she kind of was like poorly
i think she
like i think she botched saying in polo
you
not polio that's how brandon chubb would
talk yeah but brendan shaw would call it
water polio do you ever play water polio
i did with pete davidson's dick once i
swear to god
can you imagine making people that have
polio play water polo how [ __ ] mean
that would be
or amazing
well you don't really need your legs in
the water yeah you're downing that's
just you're just drowning them you have
to doggy paddle the entire time see yeah
you just got to get those arms like that
upper body and i feel like
is there something wrong with that i
feel like the wheelchair would weigh
them down i think you would take the
wheelchair off then that's not funny i
don't think you'd breathe
i said it was interesting just wheeling
somebody into a pool
hey here's a new sport
the ball with one hand and move it
around there you go professor xavier
think your way out of this one you dump
them in a pool
there you go x-man
and then just turn the magneto and go
you could have done this like 30 years
ago what took you so long jesus christ
you could have controlled this
wheelchair with your mind and puts them
in a pool
damn
it's
really an exciting game it really is
it's typically not the sport you see
played in chicago's inner city and
you guys are being you think since it's
chicago water portal thing they have to
change the nets to the metal ones like
they do with the basketball courts
chains
the usa water polo racial equity and
reform task force said
we have a [ __ ] what
and how much does that cost wait wait
wait
we have a what
a [ __ ] what
i'm backing this up that was i mean was
inner city in fact the usa water polo
racial equity and reform task force says
most
how much is that costing us do we need
that i mean
it's it's specifically for water polo
it's a water polo
rand paul's ears are bleeding right now
seriously
if you told me
that this was a parody
right
like doesn't that sound like something
like ryan long or danny would have came
up with yeah like i oh i'm from the usa
water polo [ __ ] diversity enforcement
or a family guy episode yeah it's just
so out there it's so weird
the reform task force says most players
in the united states are predominantly
affluent white individuals
and
senior khalid robinson was a footballer
jordan gordon saying there's a 1352
increase in gun violence committed in
pools
[Laughter]
come on man
senior khalid robinson was a football
player who never even considered the
sport at first i was like nah i'm not
going to do it but then she was
persistent
my coach she kept coming around every
now and then rubbing my penis and stuff
i didn't like it at first i didn't like
it but then you know it was like okay
yeah whatever
like yeah you should come to the pool
every once and then that one day i
actually did come
i actually had a whole bunch of fun
playing the game was one thing but
asking them to wade into the deep end
well that was another
come on
why are you allowed to do this
i look i want to be clear
we have not broken toss once in this
entire thing
they have
what
i don't you know this is a great story
we don't have we don't have to be right
have racy jokes they're doing it for us
you're you're acting like seeing a
couple black kids in a pool
you're reacting the way
like africans react when you do street
magic
you know what i mean like you think
you're a wizard yeah you know what i
mean like you just do a simple card
trick and they're like oh
you know like
you're acting like
i've seen black people in the water so
have i i live in their hair
i live in florida i see them in the
water actually all the time here
we don't have that stereotype
whoa a black guy in the pool get out of
town why is this so confusing for you
you usually don't see black women in the
pool because of the hair that's right
they'll go no they'll go to here they'll
go to like the boob level yeah but they
won't go above because of the hair they
don't know what their feet in the water
and do this but i don't know any black
people in florida that aren't doing
[ __ ] cannonballs into the democrats
not in florida that isn't actually that
doesn't really work here i think it's
more has to do with the fact that you
guys live in a frozen wasteland and that
if even if you owned a pool in chicago
what it would be open like a month and a
half out of the year have you seen the
pool at shaq's house because you brought
it up earlier it's huge
but they i think this is more you're
acting like whoa black kids playing
water polo and it's like i think that
has more to do with like geographics
than demons asian man with a large penis
next at five it's like it's it's more
geography than it is it's not you frozen
i know even in new york a lot of i know
a lot of people that just didn't get in
the water a lot like they just once in a
while in the summer you might go once or
twice but it's like the beach isn't as
big of a cultural thing
even in new york i've seen the movies
the dominican and black kids are playing
in the open fire hydrant
that's true yeah the fire hydrants not
you know that's not a pool though yeah
that's true but but like it's i think
it's more of a geographic thing you're
turning it into a race thing which is
weird
it's the same reason
the same reason you don't have water
polo teams in chicago is the same reason
you don't have a hockey team in miami
like in the [ __ ]
florida panthers bro i'm sure you do i
know i don't know sports but you get my
[ __ ] point
i'm just telling you guys here in
florida black people are all the time
going into pools that i won't go into
but you know and that's just
community pools yeah
panthers known for their
agility on ice they're not great on it
okay
especially when they didn't even know
how to swim the defend was really
intimidating oh my god
three seconds without them
racist [ __ ]
we just did a ten minute soliloquy on
the [ __ ] thing with
but they just said it they just said it
first off based
oh my god
i actually had a whole bunch of fun
playing the game was one thing but
asking them to wade into the deep end
well that was another especially when
they didn't even know how to swim
it feels like a black and white racist
movie before jim before jim crow was
like taken away right doesn't it
because these little pikaninis didn't
even know they could float and you're
like what the [ __ ] they have you're the
news they have their own swimming pool
it's just three fifths smaller
defend was really intimidating for me if
i didn't try it then i wouldn't i
wouldn't know how to swim
and i wouldn't be playing a water polo
for julian that's one of the first
things that they say is you know i can't
i can't go down here in the deep water
that that's too deep and my conversation
to them is but boy you're a grown-ass
man you know i guarantee you that that's
already picking up her real attitude as
a boy you a grown-ass man you're going
to learn how to swim just throw them in
this is going to be one of those movies
that if this was in the 90s whoopi
goldberg would be playing the coach
right
and it would have those underdog stories
it would be a movie in the 90s too water
polo version of cool running exactly
we don't swim on the bottom of the pool
it doesn't matter if it's seven feet or
if it's three feet it wasn't a real fear
of drowning it was just
all right i don't want to drown so
let's try to stay above the water but i
have fun for the most part it's called
swimming
congratulations
and i was always looking forward to
using water polo as a stepping stone to
help me get better at football coach i
actually like this kid you know he seems
like a nice kid she is also a chicago
police officer i could tell
i could tell she looks like a chicago
police cruiser
i thought they said we weren't giving
tanks to the police departments anymore
deep dis chicago police officer over
here
officer uno's pizza
officer who started this team from
scratch nine years ago to help her heal
from her own ptsd and fears she says
what students are to be fair normally i
would roll my eyes but if you're a
[ __ ] police officer
in chicago i think they are allowed to
have ptsd right learning here are
lifetime skills they're learning to
depend on each other and you know these
particular individuals collaborate with
other students and learning how and
basically you know by uh you know
getting these black kids to play water
polo i got them all collected in one
room and i could keep an eye on them she
looks she's about to tell she has a
bleached [ __ ]
when they get out of here you know so
when they get a job you know they're
going to deal with other people so they
got to learn how to work together with
other people water polo brings that to
the table so anytime you're able to go
ahead and get buy-in and student
interest so just get them comfortable
because for a lot of black and brown
students they don't get a chance to swim
so now just really getting that buy-in
and then getting them to learn
why but i mean do they not get a chance
or is it just not an interesting
sometimes they don't want to like i
understand a lot of weird interests on
people all the time with your little
tinkering and i don't understand it yeah
maybe they'd rather play football like
that's on them right
the sport the right way so once they
come so to be fair like you've never
heard of a water polo getting a black
guy out of the hood in basketball that
happens right will be a guy that's in
the hood and then now he's making 10
million dollars a year playing for a
team there's not how much do
professional water polo people make
that's something they show on espn
a year
the bare minimum required to file tax
returns cushy cushy cushy
and just get comfortable with the water
julian's principal lawrence spalding
says we're sorry hey coach you can hop
in the water or hell no no not me man
you missed me with that [ __ ]
the water julian's principal lawrence
spalding about 24 000 a year i was
kidding oh my god
but they have to go to europe
but that's
all your money well i guess they
probably pay for that but that's still
yeah but so that's how much a
professional european water polo player
makes how long is the season like two
months
yeah how does yeah i don't know anything
about water polo uh i'm gonna check that
i'm basically an inner city chicago
black kid i know nothing about water
polo or water for them yeah i don't know
how it works
it says for students there is a special
kind of pride that comes with being risk
takers and trailblazers that uniqueness
is just great for themselves they're
going
to make this
a movie
mark my words pay attention to what i am
saying
there's going to be a movie it might be
a direct to paramount plus movie or
direct to peacock movie
but they're going to make a movie out of
this
waterproof okay
waterproof
that's a good name
i like that i like that oh you know
what's another one the other one
sink or swim
would be a good name for the movie sink
or swim is good right the coach
recast
idris elba
will be the black coach i like it yeah
this will be iges alba right
so we'll have idris alba playing the
principal of the school james spalding
named after the
basketball and um i have a better name
for the movie
sure
oh you sound like my grandfather
i wouldn't say that
i would say that
it's a little wordy
you know
oh stephen wallin out of the deep end
out of the deep it's a good one i like
that i like that i like that
all right enough
[ __ ] jesus christmas holy [ __ ] that
was very funny and you know what maybe
even like five years ago you could have
got away with that joke
so
so there's total
in all of the the water polo divisions
in the
u.s and of the 83 total teams there's
only like four scholarships per team
okay so this isn't this is gonna get you
out of the hood this is not saving you
this is not getting you out of the hood
right play basketball is what you're
saying you're saying play basketball by
the way i'm looking on twitter and um
yes this that that was the same cody
that was that molested a kid already got
the mug shots out yeah this is
a lot of people my theory might be right
there virgie
yeah a lot of people are calling this
[ __ ] out with this guy and all you
[ __ ] right-wingers that are riding
his dick because he agrees with you on
something it's like that's why sometimes
you just have to
you know
not
anyway